字幕提供
非常的強
所以呢常常遇到那種
20分鐘也不怎麼低頭的股票
費嘎漲停
我在這天做了一個動作
這個動作我覺得蠻重要的
我在這一天呢做了兩件事
第一件事呢
我看股期所漲停之後
我盤錢立馬全部回補
我的空單全部回補啦
再跟各位講一次齁
你做股票停損10%
那的成本是非常的低
停損10%你再賺11%就回來
那但是呢你停損50%喔你要賺一倍才能回來所以停損10%我是很樂於停損的所以我在這一天呢
我記得我買我空了30張
盤中中了3張
然後呢盤後中了7張
所以這邊呢
這個一共中了10張
所以我的20張呢
的虧損呢隔天繼續
那隔天在這裡呢
我又中了3張
所以我的虧損剩17張
這邊這個位置齁 我直接做什麼事啊
在這裡呢 誰空期貨
那這個期貨是值得空的啦
來看一下 今天挑選古今小幫手
台聖哥今天的盤中呢
是有有先掌停的
那我看那個日出我覺得
我覺得沒有很強啊
沒有很強 所以我猜今天賣壓蠻大的
重點是昨天的環球晶已經殺尾盤了
好 各位看一下 昨天環球晶的長相長怎樣
昨天的合金長怎樣
昨天的合金也沒有很強
環球金也沒有很強
所以呢
同類型的台聖科今天補疊的機會其實蠻高的我今天就直接直接在盤前直接空了台聖科台聖科空漲停欸
我空漲停喔
啊我有貼在這個
粉磚上
我這邊空到了
空到了3筆
然後呢
有回補一筆在這313
大概在這邊補到的
然後到了這邊呢
這邊的人是受到假戳的影響
這邊有人在做假戳啦
我們從這個明細可以看得出來
假戳就是他會在最後5秒鐘呢 刪單
這個是刪在最後10秒鐘
他就刪單
所以說這種
跌停板掛大量的假戳騙了一堆人上車
今天有很多人以為
還勝客要打開
因為那個那個量看起來有點
看起來要開的樣子嘛
所以這邊有一堆
以為要打開的去買
然後呢
我是在做套利
我做處置賠錢 大部分都是做空賠錢
所以我常常跟學員講
你...就不要空就不要空所以我們基礎的第一招就是讓子揮頭找買點嘛那你真的要空的話你一定要做個雙刀好不好
那我們現在處置我們不只做這些
我們還做套利
處置可以做套利
就是處置套利超好套
超好套
我跟各位講
我們這個股市
我在股市裡面
從2000年到現在
已經26年
我沒有看過有一年的套利像今年這麼好做
你知道為什麼嗎
重要的原因就是
資金的成本太高了
我不說多的
光台積電我可以無風險套
幾乎無風險 激進無風險
我們之後呢 我們假如找到一個
可以讓我找到一個特殊的單位幫我們做組合彈的話
我大概可以套個20% 30%不是問題
但是我現在還沒找到這個單位
還沒找到還沒找到
欸有找到也不能跟你講
這個是秘密啊
不能跟你講
有太多東西
可以套
所以處置呢
他有太多好玩的了